did did you go to Judd Apatow with
crashing did you bring it to him you're
an Apatow man how did you did you how
did that happen
toe yeah did you bring the script to him
he got it to him what did he like your
comedy did he know you I'm gonna tell
you I can do I can do the story quickly
okay but I think it's a fantastic story
and I left thinking about it because it
it makes my heart open with gratitude
any of this happened but what happened
was I was doing a talk show called The
Pete home show which was my first really
big break right at other breaks but JP
Buck who I'm still indebted to and very
grateful for he was the comedy Booker on
Conan he kept whispering in Conan's ear
like I think the speed homes guy would
be good to host this uh a late night
show right because he wanted a protege
or he just wanted to give a kid a shot I
I can't know another man's mind and you
were you were kind of friendly with
Conan at this point on the show Once and
they were already Whispering Your
Praises well that's they wanted someone
unknown they didn't want it wasn't I'm
saying uh Wayne Brady because Wayne
Brady had a talk show I'm not teasingly
right right I didn't want the Wayne
Brady show they wanted like who the [ __ ]
is this guy which believe it or not
that's what it was when Conan was on
literally like all caps who the [ __ ] is
this guy that's when he when he first
did the Conan O'Brien show back in the
90s I was a regular recurring sketch
comedy guy oh wow and I did the
Amsterdam kids two kids who were
misinformed about Amsterdam's liberal
social policies and I did like seven
episodes I have them on tape still and
you get paid a couple hundred bucks and
go on and nobody was watching Conan
nobody knew Conan yeah they were waiting
for it to go away yeah and by today's
standards it would have yes there's
actually Conan was being renewed week by
week at a certain point by NBC which I
think is really brutal oh that's a good
story
so they're whispering in your ear though
I don't want to forget that there's an
element yeah JP Buck Right deserves so
much of this credit so does Jeff Ross
Conan's produce her not the rose
comedian anyway I do I'm writing on a
multicam on the Warner Brothers lot and
I walk over to do stand-up on Conan show
I don't know anything about the about
the them looking for a late night host I
would have been terrified I'm glad I
didn't know right but I went out and I
did my second Conan set and this is
about 50 pounds lighter than my first
Conan set first Conan set is fun to look
up the uh my Google set I'm I'm 280 like
it's a lot it's like 270 maybe it's a
lot I'm like 235 right now oh really
yeah imagine imagine 280. wow big guy
big boy big boy fun boy fun boy
anything where the name of the dish is
is the recipe I was eating it uh so
anyway the reason I mentioned that is I
I had a good breakup I needed to break
up with somebody I stopped drinking as
much I did a juice fast for 30 days like
a real L.A wow okay and then got like my
skin was glowing did Conan then that's a
whole other story uh but Judd did a
sketch for the Pete home show as it was
called we just Nick Bernstein our
producer I think just was like it would
be funny if maybe we could get Judd
Apatow maybe you pitch him a movie like
a fake movie or something that's the gag
right by the way now having known Judd
for so long that's everyone's gag